one of the jokes in the bitcoin
community is that whenever people first
learn about bitcoin all of a sudden they
have some wild idea on how to improve it
how to change it you know the old joke
i'm here from the government to save you
well that's how people basically
approach bitcoin and of course whenever
there's some sort of conflict around the
world there's massive geopolitical
change that occurs and what we're seeing
now are rumors online that russia and
their ministry of defense are thinking
about creating some sort of one world
currency we've got a tweet here that
shows that the russian minister
supposedly said they're working on a one
world one currency for trade this is the
equivalent of saying i'm here to fix
bitcoin bitcoin doesn't need to be fixed
ultimate it's a digital decentralized
currency anyone in the world regardless
of your wealth status your geographic
position or who your parents are and
what you do for a living anyone with an
internet connection can simply access
this neutral piece of technology this
open system they can buy they can sell
they can transact or they can hold it
economic value and they don't need
permission from anyone that is exactly
what we need is a decentralized system
that no one no individual or
organization controls ultimately having
bitcoin continue to get adopted around
the world it's a neutral liberating
technology it allows for people to have
digital property rights over the
economic wealth that they've acquired it
also allows them the freedom to transact
and without the freedom to transact
you're not actually free so ultimately
regardless of what russia or any other
country says or does they can take their
best stab at a central bank digital
currency or any other alternative
payment method bitcoin is the solution
bitcoin is the only piece of technology
it's not controlled by anyone it's open
for everyone and it continues to be
adopted globally